vamos a asegurarnos de que entendieron
bien lo que pasa en esta pequeña función
fibonacci iterativa que escribí voy a
explicar la paso a paso con un ejemplo
particular digamos que llamamos esta
función con el argumento 5 queremos el
quinto elemento en la sucesión de
fibonacci
recuerden que comenzamos los elementos
indexando desde el elemento 0
el elemento 0 es el que algunas veces se
considera como el primer elemento pero
en nuestro caso tenemos el elemento 0
asumiremos que llamamos a la función
fibonacci para el quinto elemento
fibonacci de 5 queremos el quinto
elemento y comenzamos con el elemento 0
y queremos el quinto y cuando entramos
en este programa definimos una lista
llamada términos que tiene solo dos
elementos
y 1 y en lo que me voy a enfocar es en
lo que pasa cuando entramos en este
ciclo cuando entramos la primera vez
término se está refiriendo a una lista
que tiene sólo dos elementos 0 y 1 y
hacemos esto porque por definición los
primeros dos elementos de la sucesión de
fibonacci son 0 y 1 y después dentro del
ciclo tenemos a la variable y definida
como 2 y es igual a 2
hicimos esto porque ya tenemos definido
el término 0 y el término 1 y ahora
queremos empezar a añadir elementos la
primera vez dentro del ciclo añadiremos
el segundo término y decimos while y es
menor o igual que n mientras que iu sea
menor o igual a n hace esto que sigue y
sabemos que n es igual a 5 en el alcance
de esta variable n es igual a 5 n apunta
5 y claramente vemos que iu es menor o
igual a n así que seguimos con el código
que hay dentro del ciclo y añadimos un
elemento a la lista términos
y al entrar en el ciclo las variables
tienen los valores que tenemos aquí y
vamos a añadir algo a la lista términos
y la lista de términos quedará con el
valor 0 1 y algo más que vamos a añadir
aquí tenemos que poner algo aquí en el
siguiente elemento de la lista términos
y lo que vamos a añadir es el resultado
de esto que está aquí arriba y parece
complicado pero en realidad es algo
sencillo en esta situación cuál es el
valor de y menos uno bueno y es dos así
que dos menos uno es igual a uno y por
acá tenemos y menos dos igual a cero en
esta interacción entonces el primer
término en términos me refiero a la
lista términos es literalmente uno y
toda esta cosa que tenemos aquí es igual
a uno y el elemento cero de términos
aquí lo voy a poner la lista se llama
términos
el elemento 0 en términos es igual a 0
así que esta cosa que tenemos aquí es
igual a 0 y 10 es igual a 1 y estaremos
añadiendo el 1 a términos y lo
escribimos aquí y hacemos y igual a 1
tenemos que ir es igual a 2 en este
momento y le sumamos 1 entonces el nuevo
valor del estrés
tenemos que 3 es el nuevo valor de y
luego vamos otra vez al inicio del ciclo
while y decimos mientras si sea menor o
igual a n y el nuevo valor de y estrés
así que se sigue cumpliendo la condición
3 está más cerca del 5 pero sigue
cumpliendo la condición y avalamos está
otra vez entramos una vez más al ciclo
términos ahora se ve así 0 1 1 y estrés
y en realidad tenemos los mismos valores
de salida del ciclo anterior y ahora
vamos a evaluar lo que tenemos aquí
vamos a añadir algo a la lista términos
así que por ahora tiene
0 1 1 y vamos a añadir al final otro
término y cuál es ese término bueno va a
ser el término y menos uno de términos y
tenemos que ir es tres así que tres
menos uno es 2 y entonces esto de aquí
ahora es 2 estamos hablando del segundo
elemento de la lista de términos este es
el elemento 0 primero y segundo entonces
esto de aquí será evaluado como uno más
y menos 2 bueno y ahora es 3 así que 3
menos dos es uno y aquí estamos hablando
del primer elemento de la lista y esto
también será evaluado como 1 y esto será
igual a 1 más 1 o 2
esto será igual a 2 entonces vamos a
añadir un 2 a la lista de términos y lo
ponemos aquí en las variables de salida
y luego tomamos lo que vale y en ésta
iteración y es igual a 3 y le sumamos 1
y redefinimos y 3 más uno es igual a 4 y
este será el nuevo valor de iu y vamos
otra vez al inicio del ciclo while
mientras si sea menor o igual a n y
ahora es 4 así que se sigue cumpliendo
la condición n 5 y 4 es menor o igual a
5 y pasamos por este código otra vez y
tratemos de imaginar cuál es el término
y menos uno de la lista términos déjenme
quitar un poco lo que escribí aquí ya se
ve un poco saturado
voy a limpiar un poco aquí así que ahora
en este ciclo vamos a escribir los
valores de entrada de las variables y es
igual a 4 y términos ahora tiene 4
elementos que son 0 1 1 y 2
y ahora 4 es menor o igual a 5 y
continuamos con el código del ciclo y el
elemento y menos 1 de términos es bueno
y menos un estrés y el tercer elemento
de términos es igual a 2 será evaluado
como a un 2
tenemos los siguientes términos 0 123
así que esto será evaluado como un 2
este 2 y le sumamos el elemento y menos
2 de términos y es 4 y menos 2 es igual
a 2 y el segundo elemento de términos es
elemento 0 primero segundo es este uno
este uno de aquí así que estamos sumando
este 2 y este 1 tenemos que el resultado
de toda esta cosa de aquí es 3 y es el
elemento que añadimos a la lista en
términos así qué términos tenían los
elementos
1 1 2 y ahora le ponemos este 3 al final
y luego decimos y es igual a 1 y es 4 4
más uno es igual a 5 así que ahora y es
igual a 5 y una vez más vamos al
principio del ciclo y ahora es 5 vamos a
poner los valores de entrada de las
variables y es 5 y término es 0 1 1 2 y
3 y luego decimos y es menor o igual a 5
y en este caso y es igual a 5
esta condición sigue siendo verdadera
entonces continuamos con la ejecución
del código dentro del ciclo y ahora
tenemos que pensar cuáles son estos
términos que vamos a sumar déjenme
limpiar esto otra vez
voy a limpiarlo otra vez y ahora cuál es
el término y -1 de términos ahora y es
55 menos 1 es igual a 4 así que es el
cuarto elemento de la lista 0 1 2 3 4
este es el cuarto elemento de la lista
es este 3 esto de aquí ahora es 3 y
ahora pensemos en este otro término y
menos dos y es 55 menos 2 es igual a 3
tenemos que sumar el tercer elemento de
la lista aquí tenemos el elemento 0 1 2
3 el tercer elemento es este 2 así que
esto que tenemos aquí arriba será
evaluado como 2
y note en esto estamos sumando los
últimos dos elementos que tenemos en la
lista así es como se construye la
sucesión de fibonacci y 325 y vamos a
añadir el 5 al final de la lista
términos así qué términos ahora será 0 1
1 2 3 y añadimos 5 al final y hacemos y
igual a 1 y el 5 así que 5 16 ahora ahí
es igual a 6 y vamos una vez más al
inicio del ciclo y decimos mientras si
sea menor o igual a n tenemos que ahí es
igual a 6 y n es igual a 5 y 6 no es
menor o igual a 5 así que esta condición
que tenemos aquí no se cumple es falso
falso y ahora salimos del ciclo y vamos
a la siguiente instrucción terminamos de
correr el ciclo y vamos a regresar el
término n de la lista términos
es igual a 5 así que tenemos el elemento
0 primero segundo tercero cuarto y
quinto regresamos el quinto elemento y
terminamos espero que hayan entendido
cómo funciona este código y también que
hayan entendido un poco la lógica de
cómo construimos la sucesión de
fibonacci empezando con los dos primeros
términos por definición y luego cada vez
que entramos al ciclo añadimos un
término al final de la lista y este
nuevo término será la suma del último
elemento que teníamos más el anterior al
último lo sumamos y tenemos el nuevo
elemento y seguimos haciendo esto hasta
que lleguemos al término n